in the spring of 2016 a legal battle
between Apple and the Federal Bureau of
Investigation captured the world
attention Apple has built security
features into its mobile products which
protect data on its devices from
everyone but the owner that means that
criminals hackers and yes even
governments are all locked out for
apples customers this is a great thing
that governments are not so happy you
see Apple has made a conscious decision
to get out of the surveillance business
Apple has tried to make surveillance as
difficult as possible for governments
and any other actors so there are really
two smartphone operating systems in the
global smartphone market iOS and Android
iOS is made by Apple Android is made by
Google so Apple has spent a lot of time
and money to make sure that its products
are as secure as possible Apple encrypts
all data stored on iPhones by default
and text messages sent from one Apple
customer to another Apple customer and
are encrypted by default without the
user having to take any actions what
this means is that if the police sees an
iPhone and it has a password they'll
have a difficult time getting any data
off of it if they can do it at all
in contrast the security of Android just
really isn't as good Android phones or
at least most of the Android phones that
have been sold to consumers do not
encrypt data stored on the device by
default and the built-in text messaging
app in Android does not use encryption
so if the police sees an Android phone
chances are they'll be able to get all
the data that they want off of that
device two smart phones from two of the
biggest companies in the world one that
protects data by default and one that
doesn't Apple is a seller of luxury
goods it dominates the high-end
of the market and we would expect a
manufacturer of luxury goods to have
products that include more features but
not everyone can afford an iPhone that's
where Android really really dominates at
the middle and low end of the market
smart phones for the billion and a half
people who cannot or will not spend $600
on a phone but the dominance of androids
has led to what I call the digital
security divide that is there is now
increasingly a gap between the privacy
and security of the rich who can afford
devices that secure their data by
default and of the poor whose devices do
very little to protect them by default
so think of the average Apple customer a
you know a banker a lawyer a doctor a
politician these individuals now
increasingly have smartphones in their
pockets that encrypt their calls their
text messages all the data on the device
without them doing really anything to
secure their information in contrast the
poor and the most vulnerable in our
societies are using devices that leave
them completely vulnerable to
surveillance in the United States where
I live
African Americans are more likely to be
seen in suspicious or more likely be
profiled and are more likely to be
targeted by the state with surveillance
but African Americans are also
disproportionately likely to use Android
devices that do nothing at all to
protect them from that surveillance this
is a problem we must remember that
surveillance is a tool it's a tool used
by those in power against those who have
no power and you know while I think it's
absolutely great that companies like
Apple are making it easy for people to
encrypt
if the only people who can protect
themselves from the gaze of the
government are the rich and powerful
that's a problem and it's not just a
privacy or cybersecurity problem it's a
civil rights problem so the lack of
default security in android is not just
a problem for the poor and vulnerable
users who are depending on these devices
this is actually a problem for our
democracy I'll explain what I mean
modern social movements rely on
technology from black lives matter to
the Arab Spring to Occupy Wall Street
the organizers of these movements and
the members of these movements
increasingly communicate and coordinate
with smartphones and so naturally
governments that feel threatened by
these movements will also target the
organizers and their smartphones now
it's quite possible that a future Martin
Luther King or Mandela or Gandhi will
have an iPhone and be protected from
government surveillance but chances are
they'll probably have a cheap to any
other Android phone in their pocket and
so if we do nothing to address the
digital security divide if we do nothing
to ensure that everyone in our society
gets the same benefits of encryption and
is equally able to protect themselves
from surveillance by the state not only
will the poor and vulnerable be exposed
to surveillance but future civil rights
movements may be crushed before they
ever reach their full potential thank
so Chris thank you so much I am I have a
question for you we saw recently in the
press that Mark Zuckerberg from Facebook
covers over his camera and there's
something with his headphone mic jack so
I wanted to ask you a personal question
which is do you do that and then on
behalf of everyone here Stickley myself
should we be doing that should we be
covering these things so putting a
sticker or actually like band-aids
because you can remove them and put them
back on whenever you want to make a call
or a Skype call putting a sticker over
your webcam is probably the best thing
that you can do for your privacy in
terms of bang for buck there there
really is malware malicious software out
there that can take over your webcam
even without the light turning on this
is used by criminals this is used by
stalkers you can sort of by 1999 spy on
your ex-girlfriends software online it's
really terrifying and then of course
it's used by governments and there's
obviously a sort of sexual violence
component to this which is that this
kind of surveillance can be used most
effectively against against women and
and other people who who can be shamed
in our society even if you think you
have nothing to hide at the very least
if you have children teenagers and
you're in your lives make sure that you
put a sticker on their camera and
protect them well thank you so much
thank you thanks Chris